redefining failure that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
today was one of the worst days the
bidet administration has had since its
inauguration now two things have now
become undeniable for everybody but
slavish biden apologists
number one
americans are getting poorer
number two
america is getting weaker
yet the white house of course is trying
to spin gold out of goose poop
after they spent all week trying to
redefine the term recession
the gdp number came out and naturally
it's worse than expected
additionally two successive quarters of
negative economic growth has been deemed
a recession
and confirmation of that ugly reality
came today looking back on this we
probably may say that you know the us
descended into a recession starting
around the middle of this year we're
gonna hear from the president it's
coming out obviously because he knows it
was bad news this morning
remember getting you used to living with
less is their policy
but they also know that the r word hurts
them politically so they just ignore the
numbers
biden may be coveted free but today he
was also fact-free
let me just give you what the facts are
in terms of the state of the economy
businesses are investing in america at
record rates we have a record job market
of
record unemployment this is powering the
strongest rebound in american
manufacturing that doesn't sound like a
recession to me thank you very much
you never see him walk faster than when
he's leaving the press now literally
everything you just heard him say is a
lie
businesses are reducing their
investments more americans have entirely
giving up given up looking for work and
pay raises are nowhere near keeping up
with inflation
so the media if we you know had a media
they should be asking biden why his
views on the u.s economy are so much
rosier than the imf's
under trump we have the strongest
economy of the g7 remember that and now
we're tied with france in fourth place
with a 2.3 percent gdp
france
just that is embarrassing and the
projections get even worse for 2023
we drop to 1
gdp
now the imf reports that the risks are
overwhelmingly tilted to the downside
that's a quote
and yet listen really closely as biden's
crew again try to redefine failure
now there's no doubt
we expect growth to be slower lasted
than last year
but that's consistent with the
transition to a stable
steady growth being what we're seeing is
that we are in a transition we had this
strong economic growth and now what
we're seeing is a transition into stable
and steady growth this report indicates
an economy that is transitioning to more
steady sustainable growth
more like transitioning to permanent
decline which is what they want
use less travel less
prosper less expect less
biden's propagandists think americans
are stupid but they are not
no is that americans hate this economy
right the cnn poll out recently found
that 64 of americans believe the u.s
economy is currently in a recession
remember this is only going to get worse
under biden's policies and things will
get more not less expensive after the
spending explosion on that climate
crapola meanwhile things are getting
more dangerous on the national security
front
chinese president xi and biden spent two
hours today on the phone and basically
it looks like china spent the entire
time lecturing us and warning biden
the ccp's readout went like this
china firmly opposes separatist moves
toward taiwan independence and
interference by external forces
the position of the chinese government
and people on the taiwan question is
consistent those who play with fire will
perish by it
it is hoped that the u.s will be
clear-eyed about this
now
those who play with fire will perish by
it
now journalists again if we have any
left should be asking the white house if
china accurately captured what was said
and if so
press them on why but biden just didn't
end the call immediately they're
threatening the speaker of the house sir
so biden looks incredibly weak here
for two years the biden people have been
sucking up to china and for what because
john kerry thought china was going to
help us on the climate change issue but
of course the communist party is playing
all of them
it doesn't give a rat's you know what
about carbon emissions it doesn't
ever feel constrained by the rules-based
international order and it never
operates in good faith never
it's a dictatorship kids
just ask jack ma from alibaba
they just took his multi-billion dollar
company from him why
because they can
our big corporations and banks doing
business there will ultimately suffer
the same fate it's only a matter of time
so biden and she apparently also talked
terrorists that's the only thing she
really cares about obviously china wants
them removed
now this would make china only richer
and stronger and american manufacturing
weaker
so of course biden's actually thinking
about doing it you can't make this up
this is insane
unless this is all part of biden's plan
of course
meaning whoever controls
biden's plan now binding the democrats
have put america behind the eight ball
here
this is an emergency that requires a
radical change in leadership in congress
of course later on in the white house
if you ever want this country to be
strong again
to our our families to be prosperous
again your streets to be safe again
we have to get rid of these people and
that means taking back the senate every
seat is critical
so a vote in georgia for raphael warnock
is a vote for decline
a vote for john fetterman in
pennsylvania is a vote for high energy
prices
a vote for tim ryan in ohio is a vote
for high food prices
a vote for mark kelly in arizona is a
vote to send more american jobs overseas
none of these people none of them are
moderate
they're in lockstep with biden and
schumer
all current or future enablers of this
unfolding american tragedy
so they can try to redefine decline as
success all they want
but it's not going to work
americans like winning too much
and today it became clearer than ever
that biden only knows how to lose
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else